[Music]
and is with us in Minneapolis welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show and thank you very
much say I have a question for you I
need some help getting the fire burning
in my husband to get out of debt we
consolidated a long long time ago when
we first got married
and we got rid of that debt you know and
it just started all over again with the
wonderful credit cards and he takes care
of the checkbook he pays off the bills I
just I don't know I know we have dealt
debt and I want to get rid of it but
every time I'm like oh by the way I
listen to Dave Ramsey today on Facebook
and he says to do this this and this and
he's like oh brother so I mean we did
your course he was really fired up about
it but I don't know it's just it's a
spiral I don't know how to get out of it
he went to Financial Peace University
the classes for nine weeks yes we did we
did it through our church and you do not
participate in the budget well why I I
don't know why he we we couldn't I don't
know we had everything we had all the
tools that you give us it sounded why do
you know why do you not participate in
the budget because I'm not involved in
any of them paying bills why he likes to
do it I'm I am every month to let me in
on it and he's just not letting me and
mm-hmm
why I don't know I think he's scared
like if he if he doesn't feel the
controls I think it's a really big
control issue I I want I can just feel
how much I want to get out of debt and I
know it's a hard thing I get it and I
know we would have to like you know
he beans rice for whatever I don't care
I just want to get out of that I want to
be able to to live like no one else okay
well nothing's going to change until
something changes yeah so you're gonna
have to change something and I guess
it's how your inner day interacting with
him because this sounds like the the
starting of working together on this is
being blocked by other issues that are
in your marriage mm-hmm and I mean
because money flows to what's important
in your household and if he controls the
money he controls what's important in
your household it's not just a control
freakin on the money he's controlling
everything mm-hmm
and that's a marriage breakdown yeah
you're not being the good little wife
you know you're being left pretty
vulnerable here because you don't have
your vote does not count in this
relationship and that's disrespecting
you mm-hmm so you know you can decide
how big a deal to make out of this but I
think if you can't if he will not allow
you to participate in the handling of
the money regardless of Dave Ramsey and
either Dave Ramsey if he won't allow you
to participate in the handling of your
money then you've got a marriage issue
yeah and I'm gonna force a marriage
counseling my appointment or sit down
with my pastor as a marriage counseling
appointment or something like that and
go listen I'm I'm just not and I
wouldn't bring it I wouldn't it's not a
debt issue at first it's not a budgeting
issue at first it's not a I want to
retire with dignity or build wealth
issue at first at first part is we need
to be working together and I'm not okay
with that
that we're not and I would first solve
that problem and then when you're
working together then you have the
opportunity to have a conversation once
your vote counts in this relationship
then you have a copper tunity in the
conversation to you know to start
talking about okay look I think we could
roll up our sleeves here and do some
beans and rice and get out of debt but
there's no sense of having that
discussion until you have a
yeah and so I'm forcing the vote I'm
gonna call for a vote here on the floor
of the floor of the Senate and you know
I may be fear on his part it may be
control on his part usually control is
somewhat fear based see they're angry
but anger based or fear based and you're
gonna find out which one soon as you
start pushing these buttons and then go
back through Financial Peace University
go to come to our live event we're going
to be there in Minneapolis we announced
it this week we're going to be there
October the 29th I'll give you two
tickets right now since you're already
customers and but don't wait until
October to address this you know be
already on your way and let October be a
pep rally for you so hold on I'll have
Kelly pick up we're going to give you a
couple tickets to Minneapolis and we
appreciate you calling in